all right
all right well it's beauty week so we've
got some nail news in style reports that
for your fall manicure we're going back
to black yeah lots of people are going
with a dark vampy nail here's megan fox
look megan the stallion
as well i love all these mega i know
kourtney kardashian just showed off an
engagement ring she got from travis
parker she was also wearing the shade
called jet black by the gel bottle ink
you see it right there oh i love the
specificity and i will have you know
that
oh i am an eye
so um i did this right before i came out
and i've never done it before and i
smeared it everywhere all over my white
shirt and i tucked myself in
so um
can i pull it off do i look like a bad
boy i think you look really good and
also like instead of wearing like a
playful colorful sweater you are giving
me like sexy businessman who is a little
bit of a bad boy am i oh
okay i've never done that before that's
a first
i'm putting the man in manicure yeah you
are
i don't know did i nail it i think you
did i think you did all right next up
check out the stunner on the new
december issue of vogue it's sarah
jessica parker
and just like that she's looking radiant
because they are celebrating the release
of and just like that which finally
comes out on hbo max next month this is
the revamp of sex in the city we've been
talking about it all year yes i told i
told santa what i brought it and he's
bringing it to me sex and the city's
back thank you so much uh and you
remember i mean this article
she goes deep talking about lots of
stuff i love it it's very refreshing for
me to hear a woman say that this is a
misogynist time they were totally you
know
kind of read the riot act for when they
stepped out in their and just like that
you know promo photo
and would that happen to
men and i just appreciated that she sort
of posed that question because
my answer would be probably not
um i think men we think get better with
age and we have to have that same
narrative for women and i did appreciate
hearing it from bubbly carrie bradshaw
just going look
i don't like it well she talked about
how she was snapped going out uh in
public with andy cohen and she had like
gray roots showing and she got all this
hate online for having gray roots next
to andy cohen
was totally gray and no one said
anything about him right there lies the
injustice well and now i just get ticked
off because you know it's
just let her eat lunch and this actually
dovetails really beautifully into our
next story okay i'm very excited about
this i'm very passionate about this
story
check this out
talk about someone who doesn't know what
they are who they want but boy did they
make a decision there's some science
news that is gonna blow your mind
everybody buckle up the washington post
reports that scientists have made a huge
discovery
female california condors can reproduce
entirely on their own
with no help from a male what now to
quote the great annie letticks and
aretha franklin these condor sisters
aren't doing it for themselves
but
there are some reptiles and snakes and
scorpions that can reproduce asexually
but it's uncommon among birds and
scientists call it parthenogenesis
partheno for virgin and genesis for
birth but the two female condors that
produced the male offspring well they
weren't virgins they had reproduced with
males before and had full access to
fertile males but decided to lay eggs
solo
[Laughter]
so they don't they're just like i'm good
dude i don't need you
i mean
good for them but
aren't you bored right
don't you don't you miss the way he
nibbles at your neck with his beak don't
you miss that
wait hold you in his wings don't even
miss him um you don't need him but you
miss him i mean
this is fascinating i hope that even
though these condors can do it alone i
hope they still flock together a little
bit
[Laughter]
it was just
a very interesting story
i love it i love this um
i also think that this totally gives me
jurassic park vibes when they're like
they can't mate it's all females and
jeff goldblum says nature finds a way
[Music]